- I got a few cousins that know
their "Glow-chest-ers"
from their "Glow-sters".
(buzzer buzzing)
So, I think I can do this.
- [Voiceover] "Bill-rica."
- It sounds like someone's name.
- "Bill-air-ica."
- It is an alternate name for America.
- Is the double L pronounced
like a Y like in Spanish?
- "Bee-yer-ica."
- How else can you
possibly pronounce this?
- "Bill-rica."
Then where's, there's an E there
that everyone's forgetting about!
- I like it better as "Bill-air-ica".
It's more patriotic.
- [Voiceover] "Glaw-stir."
- Like, there should be an H in here.
And then I would know how to say it.
- "Glow-sister."
- "Glow-chester?"
- "Glow-stir."
Next.
- Noooooo!
I've been doing it wrong this whole time.
- It's "Glaw-stir", it's that simple?
- [Voiceover] "Co-chich-you-it."
(laughs)
- This one is really hard.
- What?
- "Co-chee-twa-tay."
- "Cotch-uh-watt-ay."
- "Cuh-shis-too-ay."
- "Cotch-i-twait."
- Sounds like a curse word.
(bleep bleep)
- "Coach-i-twit?" (laughs)
Wow.
- Are they just trying to trick you?
- [Voiceover] "Lemon-stir."
- "Leo-minster?"
- "Low-minster."
- "La-minster."
- "Lemon-stir?"
- What the hell happened to the O?
- [Voiceover] "Lester".
- What the hell?
There's too many E's in this word.
- "Lie-stir."
- "Lie-sister."
- "Lee-stir."
- "Less-is-tur."
- I don't even know what
sounds letters make anymore.
- "Lester?"
- Nailed it.
- Hold up a second.
- I know someone named Lester,
and that's not how it's spelled.
- Why even have all these letters
if you're not gonna
use 'em, Massachusetts?
- [Voiceover] "Hey-ver-ill."
- I would say "Have-er-hill", but,
by my knowledge of today,
it's probably like,
it's probably just pronounced "hill".
"Hah-vur-hill."
- "Have-er-hill."
How do you mispronounce that?
- "Have-er-hill", I'm saying every letter,
for the sound that the
dictionary gives it.
- "Have-uh-hill?"
- "Hey-vur-hill?"
- Harry Potter hill?
- "Hivv-er-hill."
- "Avril."
- "Hey-ver-ill?"
Oh my gosh.
- Not a real word.
- Either pronounce them
the way they're written,
or write them differently, Massachusetts.
- [Voiceover] "Wuss-ter."
- This one I know because
it's like the sauce, right?
"War-chest-er, War-shuss-ter" sauce?
- "War-shiss-ter."
- "Worse-ter."
- "Wah-sister."
- "Wuss-ter."
Yeah.
- "Wuss-ter?"
- Let's ignore R's, and (bleep) it,
let's ignore C's and E's too.
- This is why the rest of America
doesn't like to hang out with you.
- (sighs) I'm never
going to Massachusetts.
- I just don't know how anyone ever knows
where they're going,
because if someone was like,
go to "Wursh-er" or, what is it?
"Wuss-ter", I would look
on the map for five hours
and be like, this isn't
a place, I'm going home.
- You know, did I do
my family proud today?
No, I did not, but...
go Red Sox!